[تصفيق]
مدينه دهجلانه الصغيره تستقبل جثه احد
ابنائها
ملاكم يقول الناشطون انه توفي متاثرا
باصابته من قبل قوات الامن الايرانيه
فالمدن الكرديه في ايران تشهد تصعيدا في
منسوب العنف ولا سيما في مدينتي
الاحتجاج بدعم شخصيات الايرانيه عامه قوات
الامن اوقفت الممثله انجامه لتحقيق معها
بتهمه التحريض ودعم اعمال الشغب وذلك بعد
ما خلعت حجابها على الملا في فيديو لدعم
حركه الاحتجاج وحتجزت في وقت لاحقا
رياح في اطار القضيه نفسها شخصيات اخرى
استدعاها القضاء كمدرب نادي بيرسو بوليس
لكره القدم
سوري وعشيه مباركه ايران وانجلترا في قطر
وصف كابتن المنتخب الايراني احسان حارس
صافي الشعب الايراني
ضاع حقوقيين قتل اكثر من 400 متظاهرا في
ايران وتجاوزت عمليات التوقيف 16 الف
توقيف الاحد حكمت المحكمه الثوريه في
طهران على شخص سادس بالاعدام على خلفيه
مشاركته في الاحتجاجات وتعتبر السلطات
الايرانيه لاحتجاجات اعمال شغب دبرها
اعداء البلاد في الخارج